I so you guys some people keep tweeting
at us watch that show the floor is lava
have you seen it now I haven't seen it
but I've seen a bunch of tweets oh my
[ __ ] god so you watch it I've never
seen a more expensive shitty show it's
crazy it seems like they spent half a
million dollars and $50 at the same time
okay
the editing is is at least four steps
below a standard youtuber like I will
stand 'red youtuber in my opinion
understands you know comedic puncheon's
yeah some effects here and there and how
to this [ __ ] is edited like someone just
learned how to be funny it's so bad it's
overwhelming the amount of like bad cut
ins and effects it's like they're using
the lite version of imovie that's just
standard ly loaded on yeah brand new
macbook air yeah yeah and the comedic
timing is awful okay like what they'll
do is every time someone the their
obstacles are so cheap and and not cheap
I shouldn't say that officers are not
cheap but the material most of it
doesn't have any flex way what's the
show what is it oh I thought you knew
no it's basically American Ninja Warrior
with the least athletic people ever and
the inability to work in teams okay and
they have to get across a room where
it's filled with red liquid okay and all
the obstacles to pop over are themed in
in the way of like science or history
and it's in it's an escape room covered
with a water like element it's really
weird like three feet like if my I
watched two episodes one of them is
hilarious it's three teachers and you
know of course the only way teachers can
get money is to go compete on a Netflix
show yeah called you know the floor is
lava yeah yeah and and there it's it's
so sad because they're thinking you know
we're hoping we get some new furniture
for the break room and I just know that
they're teaching every day in their
break room it's just like a beanbag from
1990 yeah and a fold-out chair and a
broken microwave and they're like well
if we win the game show
and it's learning themed so the kids
will love it that's one of the obstacles
in the in the thing it's like we took
your table from the nine the 1960s
that's broken and you have to fix it
there's no fixing this [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
so the the main thing is that because
they're unathletic the obstacles are
just far away enough from each other for
example in the planetarium okay they
have the planets and then the earth is
flat it's a little a little bit of humor
there okay earth is a flat platform but
the rest of the planets are around Wow
gotcha okay so these round like I don't
know what is flat though for real there
oh yeah yeah we're flat earthers by the
way yeah casually by the way anyways
yeah it's the only accurate
representation of the earth so so the
most because they jump onto the [ __ ] and
the material doesn't flex there's no
like grip and it's covered in the red
goop so when they land on it they just
like bump it okay and they can't get
traction and they slip off okay designed
for anyone who's not six five to lose
okay so hold on can I ask a question
real quick yeah so is the idea behind
this they take smart people who aren't
athletic like people that like teachers
that know how things about history and
stuff like that sure and they put them
in this course now it's it's it's random
it's little art I don't get the point
like exactly okay I don't understand the
point of show either it's just for them
to get from one side of the room to the
other so that's why it it's just
basically an escape room gotcha okay and
you know they try to draw you in with
you know a mom and her two kids trying
to get money for college or a teacher
and you know it's it's it's a weird the
whole like the production it feels like
a Tim and Eric bit like you're waiting
for someone to just vomit spaghetti and
like you know to just like do something
[ __ ] absurd because the whole premise
and the wage shot is so bad I I cannot
stress enough how awful it is so the
only joke and only bit of humor and the
whole thing is when they slide off one
of the things the editor takes that
impact and he edits it to a song
so okay like oh man he really took a
spill there then they bring in I don't
know Beethoven or whatever's like Ben
and oh man that's the only it's every
time someone eats [ __ ] that's the only
bit of humor and and the cuts extend way
too long you're looking at this bit go
for at least 60 seconds maybe a minute
20 and you're sitting there feeling this
should wrap it up be I got it and
they're just trying to fill out the show
wait is this a Netflix it's Netflix dude
Netflix needs a new reality person
mm-hmm whoever is in charge of buying
their reality oh my good ol white that
all these shows that are it's like
what's the package like what is the
point of the show what's the what's the
hook what's the line yeah it's always
something that doesn't hold up yeah it's
not like tested if someone comes through
and goes like did like the too hot to
handle one they go yeah what about if
you put all these hot people in a house
but say they can't [ __ ] someone's like
wow that's a great concept for like ten
minutes yeah and then after that usually
well I don't want to I don't want to see
any funny it was funny for a sec but now
I'm ready yeah so bet you later that
sweaty come on make sure that whole cast
started a group only fans millions
overnight oh yeah they're mad famous are
they yes well that's just goes to show
how much reach netflix have yes it's
incredible yeah by oh they just need to
[ __ ] like make a good reality series
and I don't mind that you're doing
reality TV I think it's cool I like
these cheap shows like I think it's a
good angle that Netflix is taking yeah
um I just it just needs to be something
like stands the test of time like no
season two of too hot to animals gonna
be brutal
yeah you like in terms of light you
think it'll be unenjoyable yeah no one's
gonna watch it I feel like bro I was
just crying laughing at that show
because the obstacles that are not it's
so it's when when people in the first
episode they had these triplets and they
had athleticism like these do it man
they just don't stop talking they don't
work together and they keep making these
bad jokes to each other and it was it
was so overwhelming if you have anxiety
don't watch that show it's it's just
like like badgering like the they don't
edit the dialogue in a way that's
cohesive it says I gotta get to the no
you get it no give me a hand me the damn
give it to me give no no don't don't
jump don't jump oh man looks like she's
gonna jump down dude give it to me Joe
it's that 4:30 just thirty minutes
straight and and whenever someone like
had the physical capacity to do the [ __ ]
they just didn't work together so it's
so [ __ ] frustrating you're like that
I just shut the [ __ ] up and hand him the
bed I don't know man I just sounds like
a nightmare oh dude I spend I was like a
bad fever dream I spent an hour getting
mad and the only thing that was
redeeming was watching this science
teacher dude plus this guy's heart man
you know this is goofball but you know
I'm sure he's a great I'm sure he's a
great teacher man you know he's he's
this kind of teacher you want you know
but you [ __ ] it's it's so and it was
on his first you know he he likes he
scales across this wall and he you he
presses his button and a rocket comes
out of the lava which is hilarious
because it doesn't help him at all so
then he has to scale back and then he
has to just jump on this earth you know
and then so he makes it and he's and
he's okay all right and then the other
teachers has to jump over to the moon
she's trying to be nice and basically
say I know you're [ __ ] fat but just
you know whatever and you know I just
say family I've you're you're not you're
not there's a lot for you yeah so she's
like I just you know just jump over the
money goes well I've always wanted to go
to the moon I'm like
I just know famous last words yeah
there's less words any bifs it's so hard
dude and he he slides off that thing
like a [ __ ] frog is him here's the
only what song do they use oh man I'd
forget it was just some drill team free
Jesus Pavan yeah what's five what's
poppin brand-new we're just and it's
like cartoon sound effects - oh man the
teacher really Biff with there
you